I want this I'll give you a buck for it
no way the text is 12 nine bucks and
I'll give you some free business advice
deal so what's the advice yes
it's an original 1970s east-west
calfskin motorcycle jacket in perfect
condition no we're worse because you
just got played so what exactly is your
business you know how people with houses
my flip phone dolla dolla bill y'all
[Music]
unless you want the HPV that closing
legs girl is everywhere in the walls I
could like live doing this forever never
get another job again good
those shoes are ridiculous I don't know
why but I like you maybe you should pick
up couple Red Bulls into bandage because
I'm gonna your generation is so jar low
overhead spend the man harm Arjun you're
killing me
[Music]
once you lose eBay's Trust it holds a
grudge I think the best things to you
would be to move back home so I can keep
an eye on no way clay not selling
stuffed animals out of my bedroom start
my own site maybe it'll work maybe it
won't but it'll be mine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait don't
I'm so happy oh is this about how deep
[Music]
ah
[Music]
go ahead underestimate me I've got it
all
[Music]
you